[Music]
there's no way to transition here to
this next topic but I have to ask you
because I know that you were very close
very very close with Garry Shandling he
was a mentor to you you were one of the
first people I I talked to after he does
that and I know that that's you you know
all kinds of thoughts and feelings will
spin right yeah yeah there's just a lot
he was such a great comic and a great
guy very kind very generous with his
time and he nurtured so many comics that
were coming up and gave them his time
and his you know expertise and and and
it's it's just so tough to kind of
accept that he's gone
because he really changed the landscape
of a lot of television yeah yeah well I
think there's gonna French are getting
together in a little while the sort of
yeah we went to his house we went to his
house a few days afterwards and his
house that we went to so many times to
play basketball when you walked in there
after this has happened it just hit you
like a rock she can't believe that that
he's no longer around and his house all
of a sudden became like a museum you
walk into his office you see all those
notes you know and his computer and his
ham radios he was a big ham radio guy I
think the only one left you only had a
big tower over his house and he would I
don't know who you talked to with that
when you're a CB operator the truckers I
guess right
probably trying jokes out on ya confuse
truckers on the interstate yeah yeah
sounds good to me Gareth yeah I change
the ending a little bit
you